Salut Romain, ça va ?
*AAAAAAH*
Wow, qu'est-ce qu'il t'arrive ?!
Mais tu fais ce que tu veux de toute façon !
Ben...Tu veux dire qu'il va pas devenir tout noir et tomber comme un fruit pourri ?
La masturbation jouit d'une mauvaise réputation
Je parle de l'onanisme hein, se
Oui parce que c'est socialement acceptable
C'est bizarre quand on y pense
Parce que c'est juste donner du plaisir à quelqu'un qu'on aime beaucoup
Et avec son consentement en plus !
Pourtant on est d'accord, dire à quelqu'un que c'est un branleur ou une branleuse,
C'est pas vraiment un compliment
Et toutes les expressions qui tournent autour de la pratique solitaire, c'est péjoratif
Pourtant se masturber, ça contribue à la bonne santé économique du pays
Ça créé même des emplois !
Mais alors, d'où ça vient, cette détestation du plaisir auto-produit ?
Moral médiéval, dogme religieux, principe archaïque :
Ils font régner la terreur sur vos pubis,
Plongez au coeur de la haine de la masturbation.
Tout prend racine dans des vieux principes moraux
Et notamment religieux selon lesquels la sexualité
C'est fait pour se reproduire, pas pour prendre du plaisir
Mais si aujourd'hui encore, c'est-à-dire au 21ème siècle je le rappelle,
Y a des rumeurs incroyables qui courent sur la pratique en solo,
C'est parce que certains scientifiques et notamment quelques médecins
Ont entretenu tout ce grand délire,
Particulièrement au 18ème siècle.
Parmi bien d'autres on peut citer le docteur Tissot,
Un médecin suisse qui a mené un combat acharné contre l'auto-érotisme.
Dans son livre L'Onanisme : dissertation sur les maladies produites par la masturbation,
Il décrit des cas insensés de patients qui seraient devenus malades, sourds, épileptiques ou qui seraient morts de s'être trop fait du bien.
A tout ces braves médecins au service de la morale,
On doit des affirmations aussi terrifiantes qu'infondées scientifiquement, comme par exemple :
"La masturbation rend sourd"
Non. C'est pas par là que ça se passe.
Éventuellement, si vous êtes trop concentrés sur votre petite affaire,
Ça peut vous empêcher d'entendre les gens arriver dans votre dos,
Mais non, ça rend pas sourd.
Ça rend pas aveugle non plus.
Ni chauve.
Ni...
"La masturbation provoque des problèmes d'éjaculation précoce"
Non.
Ça peut même être un très bon moyen d'apprendre à gérer son excitation et à contrôler l'éjaculation !
Bon, évidemment faut prendre son temps, faut faire ça bien, OKLM,
Pas le matin dans la salle de bain en mode "go fast"
"SORS SORS SORS SORS !"
"La masturbation rend stérile !"
Non plus hein.
Bon chez les femmes on voit vraiment pas pourquoi,
Mais chez les hommes non plus en fait !
Les spermatozoïdes sont fabriqués en permanence depuis la puberté jusqu'à la mort,
Quelle que soit la fréquence des éjaculations.
Bon c'est vrai que si vous voulez faire un bébé vaut mieux espacer les rapports sexuels de 48h pour laisser le temps au stock de se renouveler,
Mais il ne se renouvelle pas moins bien si vous consommez plus que d'habitude.
C'est même le contraire en fait ! Mais on en reparlera plus tard.
"La masturbation affaiblit le corps et l'esprit !"
Nul. Zéro.
Bon ok, après un orgasme, qu'il soit masturbatoire ou pas d'ailleurs,
Les endorphines libérées par l'organisme, ça provoque un sentiment de plénitude, d'euphorie, un relâchement musculaire voire un petit coup de pompe.
Mais c'est passager ! Et évidemment à long terme ça entame ni votre force physique ni votre volonté.
Ça colle même plutôt la pêche !
Mais ça aussi on va en reparler.
Bon, je veux quand même pas mentir : il y a quand même des risques.
Les médecins allemands ont rapporté le cas d'une jeune fille de 24 ans qui est décédée d'une rupture d'anévrisme pendant qu'elle se masturbait.
Mais ! C'est un cas extrêmement rare qui en l'occurrence était lié à deux choses :
La présence d'un anévrisme, c'est-à-dire un défaut qui fragilise un vaisseau sanguin du cerveau ;
Et l'augmentation avec le plaisir de la pression artérielle, c'est-à-dire la tension si vous voulez, qui a fait rompre l'anévrisme.
Mais la rupture d'anévrisme aurait pu être causée par n'importe quoi d'autre,
Donc pas de psychose.
Non, en réalité, le seul risque avec la masturbation, c'est qu'elle se mette à prendre trop de place dans votre vie sexuelle et même dans votre vie tout court.
Et oui, il y a des personnes qui ressentent le besoin irrépressible de se masturber
plusieurs fois par jour, de façon maladive
Parfois ça prend dans endroits pas très propices
Comme une quincaillerie par exemple
ou dans un cours de danse de salon
En plus des conséquences sociales voire
judiciaires, ce type de troubles
ça peut aussi aboutir à une incapacité totale à avoir d'autres types de rapports sexuels qu'avec soi-même
mais attention en réalité le problème, c'est pas la masturbation
Là, on a affaire à de véritables troubles compulsifs, voire à une addiction
Et ce qu'il faut c'est en rechercher les
causes, pour pouvoir les soigner
Et ça c'est chez le psy que ça se passe
Je vous sens pas bien là
Bon j'ai une bonne nouvelle pour vous quand même
La masturbation en vrai, c'est bon pour la santé
Allez, puisqu'on est plus au 18e siècle, petit tour d'horizon des bienfaits de l'auto-érotisme
La masturbation
c'est un somnifère bio !
Pendant la masturbation et au moment de
l'orgasme, le corps sécrète un certain
nombre de substances et notamment des endorphines.
Endorphine, ça veut dire morphine endogène
c'est un peu comme si le corps payait sa tournée de morphine
et du coup : relâchement, apaisement et endormissement
La masturbation ça détend !
Et oui, les endorphines toujours, elles
calment le stress et les douleurs.
Donc par extension la masturbation ça a
des vertus apaisantes, anxiolytiques et antalgiques.
Tout ça, sans ordonnance, sans effets secondaires et sans trou de la Sécu.
Allez, vous me jeter ces boîtes de médicaments et au boulot.
La masturbation c'est bon pour le coeur.
La répétition des mouvements plus...
disons l'émotion
ça accélère le rythme cardiaque donc
ça fait travailler le coeur au même
titre qu'une activité physique
modérée
comme la marche rapide par exemple
D'ailleurs, en cas de maladies
cardiovasculaires, après un accident
comme un infarctus par exemple
on peut reprendre une activité sexuelle
normale, à condition d'y aller
progressivement, et dans ces cas là
aussi la masturbation ça peut aider
parce qu'au début, pour réapprendre à  se gérer,
c'est quand même plus facile d'être tout seul.
c'est la rééducation, si vous voulez
Bonjour, je suis Jean-Michel, le kiné.
C'est vous qui avez des problèmes cardiaques ?
Ok, on s'y met...
La masturbation, c'est bon pour la prostate.
Une étude de l'université de Boston
menée sur trente-deux mille hommes
a démontré que ceux qui éjaculent le plus on
moins de risques de développer un cancer de la prostate
Bon tant qu'on est côté bourses, tout à l'heure je vous ai dis que la masturbation
ça rendais pas stérile, vous vous souvenez ?
Mais il y a une étude,  australienne cette fois,
qui suggère
que si on renouvelle régulièrement ses stocks
Et bien ça améliore la qualité et la mobilité des spermatozoïdes.
Attention, pour être honnête la majorité de ces bienfaits
sont attribuables à l'orgasme et pas
directement à la masturbation mais
avouez que même si on préfère prendre
du plaisir à 2, s'offrir un petit
orgasme à soi-même
toutes les bonnes raisons qu'on vient
voir
parfois c'est plus pratique. Parce que
quand c'est le bon moment, on est
toujours dispo, on est toujours d'accord, et on sait comment faire ça bien
Mais d'abord et avant tout, la masturbation
c'est d'abord un très bon moyen de découvrir son corps
C'est aussi un très bon moyen d'explorer ses sensations, d'apprivoiser tout ça
et de devenir un adulte épanoui sexuellement
en plus de se donner un petit peu de bien-être gratuit
C'est pour ça qu'on le fait tous et à tous les stades de notre vie
de la naissance, au grand âge, en passant par l'adolescence.
Ok, surtout à l'adolescence.
Mais pas seulement les adolescents
du côté des adultes 95% des hommes et
89 % des femmes
reconnaissent avoir recours à la pratique du plaisir solitaire
Tout le monde se masturbe, même les animaux
Vous voyez bien que c'est naturel
DTC c'est fini pour aujourd'hui
Rendez-vous la semaine prochaine pour une nouvelle vidéo
Merci à toutes et à tous d'être aussi nombreux à me suivre
à m'envoyer des messages
Continuez, abonnez-vous
Et branlez-v... ET PORTEZ-vous bien